give me a couple years  from this city  [Music]  at 26 I took an oath you know the one  I've been asked if what I did was worth  25 years  now I'm gonna see if it was  white and fresh I want you to go to  Tulsa  you serious  you need a cat so I went to the boss you  could run like crazy do whatever you  want I need to see your books are you  from the government I just knocked your  guard out and you think I'm a CPA  am I being charged with almost getting  shot because I don't think that's a  crime even in Oklahoma  what's an ex Mafia Capo going in Tulsa  and I figured that out you'll be the  second one to know I'm very excited  Amigo you're precisely where you're  supposed to be if you work for me we'll  be making money hand over fist  nightclubs disco's a disco you're a  sarcastic a little perk aren't you  give me a couple years  I want to own this city  if anybody asks you what I do for a  living tell them I'm an industrialist  what does that even mean my point  exactly  [Music]